get through this comprehensively but um
what i'd like to do today is talk a
little bit about um the perspective of
the human
um as opposed to technology and
obviously
some references to ai
um with reference to a couple of um
theorists uh nicholas lumen and hans
blumenberg
so there were a few different things
that unite these two
old german men um
both of them lived through the second
world war as young men both were highly
critical
the kinds of thinking that they felt at
that time
produced
the kind of basis for
fascist political theology
so the kind of theory of decisionism of
political control over all of society
which they both felt arose in part due
to a failure to properly understand and
adapt to the changing relationship of
humans with increasingly complex
societies
so although this work is quite old at
this point i do think it still has some
points
that are quite useful at least for me in
terms of thinking through what law is
doing
on society more generally in relation to
new kinds of ai
in particular i'd like to focus today on
the concept of consciousness which
obviously has a very complicated history
i'm sure people here know a lot more
about that history than i do
so i'm just taking one example of it but
one of the reasons why it's particularly
interesting is that when computers first
started to enter administrative
government in germany in the 1950s
legal administrative theorists
for example carl ziegler
wrote that while automation of
information processing in government
could be acceptable in order to assist
decision makers
it was really important that every
decision was processed
through the consciousness and will of
humans in order to qualify as legally
valid
and i know that translation to
a section of a really brilliant phd
thesis by dr ari edmondson who's based
here at berkeley um
i recommend looking up if you're
interested in these ideas
so for zeidler in 1959 it was pretty
trivial to say that humans have got
consciousness and well they can easily
differentiate their decisions from
automated decision making in a way
that's legally significant
but this question of consciousness and
will
was
at least for lumen and blumenberg taken
up a little bit too easily
and i think that these questions are of
course highly relevant and contested
again today
so one question we could ask is is it
possible for a machine to simulate the
qualities of human consciousness
sufficiently well in order to be trusted
to perform decisions that would affect
human rights in the legal system
but another question an anterior
question could be do humans use their
consciousness when they take decisions
as a former immigration lawyer i often
felt that the decisions that were given
by bureaucrats were there
for say rejecting asylum applications or
deciding on visas
were by no means a sort of realistic
account of what was going on in the
minds of the decision maker or even in
the priorities of the organizations that
they worked for
the reasons were given for decisions
because on one level it was the main way
that the organization reaffirmed its
identity to itself as an organization
observed legally reasons were given
simply because it was a legal
requirement that they'd be given and
that was in order to enable legal
contestation procedures
in other words the decision on my case
turns out to be factually disappointing
the law can still offer a way of arguing
that it should have been decided
otherwise
in this way reality is doubled there is
the reality of the decision and then
there is the reality of the legal
argumentation that says the decision
might be taken otherwise
what makes a decision legitimate is this
procedural possibility of contesting it
in this way law provides an
epistemological frame for seeing things
in the world differently to how they
have turned out
of course there are other ways of seeing
things economic political scientific
truth and so on
the role of the human in this
different sort of epistemological frame
or frames is to be able to understand
the meaningfulness of the differences in
seeing the world in different ways
so if an ai produces a certain
statistical truth based on its data sets
and the weights that it attaches to them
a human can see further than that can
apply legal knowledge or economic
evaluation to ai decisions
and can in theory suggest that this
decision be retaken otherwise
of course there are practical problems
with this and speaking very abstractly
the point is that each differentiated
way of observing the world produces a
different environment for itself
considers different things important
gives them different weights connects
them up to different organizations and
procedures the human operator is the one
that has the cognitive capacity to
switch between these codes
differentiating different realities
this is an at least an initial
approximation of the system's theory
approach to thinking about society but
it's the underlying epistemological
framework that i'd like to attend to
here
where hans blumenberg and lumen
converged was on the question of radical
contingency so the idea that everything
that is given could be given otherwise
both were as i mentioned before affected
by their experiences in second world war
and in particular the way in which the
order uh changed quite rapidly after the
war and they were deeply suspicious of
what might come next
they're also both deeply interested in
edmund hussarl's phenomenological
investigations into the conditions of
human consciousness and i'd like to
focus here on a 1963 piece that
blumenberg wrote
an article entitled phenomenological
aspects on life world and technization
and this was a big influence on lumen
and again ari edmondson has written
about this really brilliantly
now the question of technization
is not actually about particular devices
or techniques but about the quote
constant multiplication and condensation
of the thing world
so this is bloomingberg's approach to a
certain
attitude within consciousness that he
says emerges and his sorrow would agree
at a historical point in time it's not
something it's not as if humans are like
homo faber that we are like
anthropologically given to picking up
tools and develop developing them rather
something shifts in human consciousness
according to his sorrow and this is most
clearly differentiated for him in the
distinction between kind of medieval
religious notions of humanity as being
the center of a god-given universe
to the kind of modern attitude whereby
nature becomes the resource for human
inventiveness and for the transformation
of human nature itself
now this question of technization was a
problem for his sorrow because for him
it obscured the fundamental experience
of consciousness's self-realization so
to try to get away from the kinds of
layers of abstraction that science and
technology applied to consciousness he
posited this concept of the life world
so the kind of i'm speaking too
reductively but a kind of basic idea of
experience as it is given to an
intentional consciousness and his idea
was getting to this fundamental level of
experience would enable his philosophy
of phenomenology
to attain a kind of pre-theoretical
position and from that position to
investigate the structures that are
produced when consciousness operates on
the world
factorization was a purely
methodological process that had kind of
intervened in our understanding of our
life world and therefore obscured our
philosophical capacities
now
blumenberg's imminent critique of this
is i think quite devastating because as
soon as there's a conscious
philosophical project based on the
notion of attaining this life world
which is supposed to be what has given
itself evident
then we have this realization that the
life world is supposed to be just one
actualization of reality from a field of
possible alternatives the life world as
posited by hussarl as the basis and
horizon of other possibilities functions
as a device to prevent consciousness
from becoming aware of other
possibilities
paradox
is that every discovery of a basic life
world is at the same time the
concealment of all other possible worlds
which you sort of did accept could exist
so all experience is just an
actualization of an infinite horizon of
possible actualizations
usually's criticism of technization as
in mode of thinking rests on the idea
that scientific abstraction over
determines the appearance of the life
world but the very act of making this
life world the object of his description
destroys its obviousness it turns it
into a technical project according to
bloomberg
so what this means ultimately for
blumenberg is that we have to abandon
the idea of getting to a kind of bottom
of experience a kind of purely human
life world as it were and instead what
we have to deal with is a radical
contingency of all given experiences
so bloomberg in this way kind of
dissolves the idea of getting to any
kind of concrete humanity
this would be an impossible topic of an
infinite task
the subject instead has to be
constituted in the form of society the
nation humanity or science this is a
quote from bloomberg and indeed is a
mandating principle that ruthlessly
discards the individual's claim on
happiness as part of bleak
it's a kind of thing to say
anyway um
but the point is for bloomberg that this
actually creates a radically um
a kind of infinitely moral task right
because if we are living in a world of
pure contingency in which our actualized
reality is always selected against an
infinite horizon of possibilities and
everything could be actualized otherwise
then this has a couple of consequences
first of all it means that our
experience is always inter-subjectively
constituted what it means to be human is
something that only can emerge between
humans
we have no underlying essence outside of
this sort of project of selecting
different realities
and this is also for bloomberg what was
mistaken for a kind of abyss of nihilism
in the 19th century and created the
conditions for the rise of the kind of
theological politics of sovereignty that
ultimately led to the justifications for
nazism
lumen picks up this idea of radical
contingency as a priori of all
meaningful experience and kind of
radicalizes it into the basis for a
theory of society
for lumen this idea of radical
contingency becomes social complexity a
kind of infinitely complex society
and the theoretical relationship that
bloomberg identified between the
concealment of other possibilities when
we select one appearance forms the basis
for what lumen says social systems can
do when they reduce social complexity in
order to allow meaningful communication
to proceed
famously for lumen or maybe not that
famously society is nothing other than
communication
human consciousness this illusive
substance which evades his sorrow is
completely bracketed inside the black
box of the human body
consciousness becomes inaccessible to
communication in women's theory
communication therefore is this purely
and subject intersubjective world in
which different topics values and
experiences are produced for us and it
emerges in the medium of meaning which
is what occurs when an observer makes a
distinction between information and
utterance to produce understanding
but that's a kind of a weird formulation
it's not that important for what i'm
trying to get to today
the elementary problem for lumen is how
any communication can occur at all
lumen argues it's fundamentally
improbable that it should happen and
that it should happen successfully
intersubjectively speaking conscious
entities are trapped in the mind
and we're in a position of double
contingency in relation to one another
ego and alter ego are equally unable to
know what the other understands of them
in the way and in relation to the way
that they would wish to understood and
because we exist in an environment of
maximum contingency where the
possibilities always exceed what can be
selected
successful mutual understanding is
highly unlikely
and to even attempt communication is to
risk outright rejection so to overcome
this each subject of mind must objectify
itself as if it were the other's mind
and turn the results of that procedure
inwards to orient their actions and
responses
as ego and alter coordinate their
selections over time a system emerges
producing stabilizing redundancies that
allow communication to be sustained and
from there to evolve becoming more
complex and differentiated lumen writes
an entire semantic history of society
based on this idea and it's quite dry
but
it's quite an engaging idea right the
idea that society grows itself under its
own just under its own um autopoaces he
calls it self-reproduction a biological
concept
so each system for lumen as it evolves
over time becomes defined by the
boundary that it draws between itself
and its environment the environment is
never what is ontologically there but
what the system produces internally for
itself
every subjective communication therefore
doubles reality in line with the coding
of a system that is producing that
communication
lumen attaches this to a sociological
concept of functional differentiation to
describe what is specifically different
about modern societies
and so we would know that we're in the
system of law if we communicate about
how things ought to be done it's kind of
doubling of reality from the factual
situation we're in the economic system
if we talk about exchange values of
things or if we simply hand over cash to
pay for something
we know we're talking about politics
when we talk about decisions that should
bind everyone or consider resistance to
them
and we know we're talking about art with
aesthetics science with truth philosophy
with ethical programs and so on
the physical things bodies minds
technological objects remain in the
environment of communication this means
they can be discussed but there will
always be an irreducible gap between
thing in itself and what it is taken up
to mean
this is a constant reason for more
communication so the human subject of
contract law is radically different to
the subject of human rights law and
neither of these are particularly stable
over time the legal status of different
subjects is constantly contested both in
the applications in the individual case
and in relation to the programming of
the law itself and jurists are quite
used to this contingency we all know
that what is legal one day might become
illegal tomorrow provided the correct
procedures are followed
proceduralization is a way of dealing
with the radical contingency of modern
society
and of course you know this is where
procedures um can actually give rise to
what lumen would call the
differentiation so the us supreme court
at the minute is basically
um obviously largely delegitimized
because its procedures have become
determined so clearly by politics
leading to political decisions
now lumen's overall idea then switches
away from subject object models of
society to system environment based
models
there's a lot more that can be said
about it but in this abstract framework
i would argue that we should not be very
surprised by the recent widely reported
incident involving google's lambda
system the large language model that was
apparently talking to an employee called
blakeland wine now the wine has been
placed on administrative leave after
going public with his beliefs that the
large language model is conscious and
has a soul google stepped in at the
point which he hired a lawyer to
advocate for its constitutional rights
lambda is obviously not conscious in the
way that humans or any other mammals are
and it doesn't have a soul it should not
require any legal personhood either
but it probably can participate in
communication and therefore alter social
communication like alter society
if
that is if an observer observes that
surprising information is emerging from
the system
lemoyne asked questions about lambda as
if it were a conscious subject and it
was programmed in a way to respond to
what it
imagines if we can use that metaphor
what the ego might expect or want to
receive back so it is an artificial
participant in a situation of double
contingency contributing to the
development of a complex interaction
system based on its programming
but chatbots are only one application of
the lambda model
these systems and i i'm speaking without
any expertise here but as i understand
it the large language model can also
work in image synthesis robotic control
and other applications
generally we could say it is aimed at
producing models that can simulate the
cognitive work that the human does in
relation to switching between different
social systems taking inputs from one
medium or one domain of knowledge and
converting them to another
this is precisely what humans do
according to systems theory we act as
cognitive coupling points between
information utterance and understanding
actualizing different realities in
relation to what has gone on before
the temptation then might be to assume
that once a model like lambda can
accurately simulate the cognitive
performance of the human agent to a
sufficiently convincing level at least
to an outside observer the ai somehow
enters society and takes on the roles
that are currently reserved for humans
however i i want to stress here that
this is not what i think
um i think this is definitely flattening
that things out way too much and it's a
bad reading of the theory and i
completely agree with the points that
thomas was making on this as well
because but i would say it's because
contingency re-enters the picture
women's idea is not really a smooth
world of social system but of social
systems that sustain themselves easily
but a fragile world of contingency and
risk
so causality is always the attribution
of connection events and even this will
always sorry always be subject to doubt
so um
i'll probably just leave it there but
what i would just basically say is that
as a source of um research i
would endorse of what's what's been said
before because
the point is that when these systems
enter into communication and are
assigned different tasks the contingency
of what they're deciding is the thing
that radically
disrupts our existing
norms and stabilized programs
and so the sites of research i think and
i think again i agree with what has been
said already today
is going to be at the level of
organizational responses rather than
overarching legal programmatics
[Applause]
over there
and
meanwhile everybody think about your
questions
and comments
oh wow that's nice
i i'll
monitor the hand raises
crack
if you have specific questions
for specific speakers
that's great
general
strength
thanks thanks helen thanks to three uh
wonderful presenters a really fantastic
way to start this
event
thanks uh hopefully everyone can hear me
um
so the thing that i was thinking about
as i heard all three papers was the
central importance of limits and
limitations in
for humans
um
and it occurred to me that the papers
were processing that
kind of how we orient ourselves in
relation to those limits in different
ways and sometimes i felt um bennett's
paper this sort of um
the power of an explanatory framework
that
handles the question of human limits
you know very globally or very easily
and says yeah there are other things
that can do what you need to do within
this kind of systemic approach
uh and so we should perhaps drop some of
these sort of hard project whereas in
other settings um
uh limits were tremendously important in
tom's paper i was thinking about the
limits of the design and we have this
fantasy of handing over design to this
human agent who can
you know engineer this new system but
actually one key message i think from
tom's paper is that
designers are extremely limited in their
agency precisely because of kind of
systemic inception and other effects and
contextual effects
and then
china talking about um
the sort of
working with that limit constructively
in order to
think about better outcomes so i'm just
wondering if how important is this theme
of limit limitations of humanity um to
how we're going to how you all three are
looking at
your next research steps
great um let me just
give a few
pointers we have
the discussion can go until
approximately 11 since we started
a bit late if things are very active
maybe we'll push
everything a little later into the lunch
and then after that there's a very quick
um break for coffee i think there's
still coffee and breathe outside and
then
the other thing is that not everybody
has to answer every question
okay
that's it
thanks
do you wanna
watch
anybody
thanks um
yeah
so thanks for the question yeah i agree
that the notion of limit is is
absolutely central to um
so to what i was describing and i also
agree i think what all three of us were
describing um i guess from my point of
view
one of the things that falls out because
what i was trying to do in in the paper
that that talk was based on was really
articulate what a
a productive
theory of politics would be in the face
of
arbitrarily capable
uh ai systems
and
for me and i i think the framing of um
of double contingency is actually very
relevant here although that's not the
language i was using
i'll just say very briefly that
um
the the limits that i have as a as a
cognitive kind of encephalized homo
sapiens um
which exists right and they're important
um are in some ways i think
interestingly surpassed or
like interacted with by these new kinds
of systems we're building but those
limits
in so far as i'm that are not the same
as my limits as a as a consumer or as a
citizen
uh or as a different kind of
of agent acting as part of a polity and
i think a lot of the
the problem we face now is how do we
re-articulate the limits of polities
in the face of
systems that i think in many ways
rightly can claim to surpass our limits
as
somatic beings uh
yeah i'll just leave it there
and you want to raise your hand
i'll write your name down and then you
don't have to
answer
yeah thank you for the question i really
love that question i think i want to
highlight i think in my work and i think
i speak for a lot of designers and
people who build ai algorithms and
systems
i think there is
it's very important to have an
a productive definition
of
limitations
um
[Music]
and that is really difficult and i used
writing like email smart compose as an
example at the end of my talk because i
think that really shows how difficult it
is to articulate how a system is limited
it's easy to say oh look these systems
you know automated people's
thinking process in writing
they took away humanity but those i
don't think are particularly
helpful in
solving the problem
um in that it doesn't tell me what i can
do to fix it
well as all these i think a tricky part
of ai's limitations is that they are all
contextual they're all dependent on
like that personalization over time and
then the specific writing context
immediately above and after you and then
from people who are similar to you
i think a lot of the work itself is to
articulate that
workable definition of harm
um
um suleim berget
and nlp had this very elegant framing
and saying
the biggest problem in nlp in fixing
nlp's biasing problem is the failure of
imagination and we cannot even
articulate how it's failing for whom in
what context
and i think that's
that's uh to our question like that's a
big question that we think about in our
work it's like
yeah i understand there are a lot of
problems there but like what can we do
thank you
uh yeah thanks i i think um
i don't have a very uh
sophisticated response but i think that
the
interesting thing for me is that um
the way in which certainly in legal um
discourse and legal writing around how
to respond to i i really just pay
attention to it in the context of
administrative and public law
which is as i said very different from
other contexts
doctrinal scholarship is very much
reaching into its own resources and
trying to imagine what they might look
like differently
and so there's a sort of
falling back into legal theory um but
legal theory arguably isn't
um as and you know this is a critical
scholar you know this is kind of what
critical legal studies is all about it's
like that's not really what's been going
on
and it's unlikely to be
what determines how these things work
out in the future and so the kind of
because i'm still thinking you know i've
sort of been immersed so much in systems
theory again which is kind of
it's a bit of a headache but you know in
a way like this i keep coming back to
this idea of contingency and
unpredictability and the likelihood that
where these where the significant action
happens is going to be the level of
organizational changes
and because of that the responses to it
and according to sort of
legal programmatics
may not really be that important you
know it's much more i mean we already
see multiple examples where the way that
ai systems are being deployed to
um perform what looks like a kind of
legally valid decision is being
radically contested because it's it's
understood very well to be a disguised
political decision or a kind of really
brutal economic decision to just do away
with people's jobs or livelihoods
and so at that level it functions
it stays in the environment right the
device itself stays in the environment
where it feeds on what resistances it
creates um are kind of just radically
diffused so yeah i mean that's not a
great answer but that's how i think
about it
thanks i think we'll take two questions
and then throw it back to the panel uh
tony and if
folks don't mind introducing
yourselves they're
interesting
i was thinking specifically about the
artificial heart replacement but it may
be generalizable as well i wonder has
computer analysis evolved to the point
where you could take the verbal content
of these doctors meetings or even
individual doctors comments and
incorporate them into the training set
and use this information
to uh to inform the ai process and
i think what might make
the medical profession a lot more
comfortable in accepting the ai results
and if we're not there have you think
we're very close to it or far away
yeah i guess this question is for young
about the
your case
and i was specifically thinking how tom
was bringing up at the beginning how do
you test and prove that this is really
augmenting some aspect of
that's humanly beneficial so i'm
wondering like do you test then the
accuracy of it what about the feedback
like maybe it shows that there's a
greater chance of people dying but like
you said the physicians might be in a
hard case like maybe i would choose 20
of living and then um what about how do
you test the impact so there's this nice
little screen and then you said that the
interns at the back could say but look
doctor but how do you actually test that
that's making some kind of a good impact
in terms of bringing that decision in
thanks
yeah thank you for both the great
questions uh um for the first question
and the first question
is about whether we can incorporate some
of those discussions
into
into the ai training set um there is i
would say that
so that's a problem that researchers are
actively working on meaning that there's
hope but it's also probably not like
real world ready
immediately um
but i also want to bring up one saying
is that for doctors these systems are
everything they put into the system
they become legally liable
um they cannot they wouldn't write down
i'm considering this patient for her
implant because once they put it down
and then let's say the patient died
overnight they're now
liable for that lawsuit um
so what we see a lot in practice is in
in clinical notes people are like
writing in codes basically communicating
to each other in a very encoded way to
say um i think this might be good and
and i don't think it's a really
difficult task for nlp and if the nlp
becomes more sophisticated i think
people will just even say less like
they you'd be surprised how much
discussion happens over you know
whatsapp um
on those cases so there are i think
organizational challenges around there
that's more than just the ai
um
and the second question is about how do
we measure better decision um
that's really really difficult i think
for the case that the for the heart
implant case that i spend most time
talking about
uh
there's no i think a good
way of evaluating the quality of an end
of life decision
part of the point is that like part of
the takeaway is that like uh
mortality maybe is not the best outcome
people don't necessarily want to go
through two open-heart surgeries and
you know spend a lot of money on and and
compromise their quality of life for
that extra
six months of life let's say
so so part of the complexity is there is
no good decision
so in that in our project we really used
deliberation as a proxy for success
meaning we assume the more you've
thought about this the more
comprehensively you have thought about
this the better the decision is
um but in the cancer diagnosis case
there is actually like a good
qual like there is a ground truth like
uh
the cancer there is cancer that isn't
cancer so so there we do see measurable
improvements there
is a lot of things this
one of the themes of this
um this grouping has raised is
that
you know i
the introduction say hey i
even said today what is the conception
of the human that is embodied or
represented in the ai system but
um as you teach broadcasting different
ways what is the conception of humanity
that
any political system bureaucratic system
any kind of decision system medical
system
um has to build into its web operating
we should be exposed to that okay so now
i'm going to take jake and lee
anybody else tina
jake
uh thanks those were all really really
interesting um i enjoyed hearing them a
lot and i suppose what they
for me all sort of bounced off was a
particular
diagnosis
of
[Music]
the unknowability
of the world and the relationship to
automated systems to this sort of
unknowability
and in you know
in tom's in tom's presentation it was to
do perhaps with
like norms broadly construed and and and
and therefore this paradigm of norm
normative indeterminacy sort of
capturing that and then similarly in
berners with this
um problem of of in not able not being
able to capture experience and and the
contingency of all experience and then
in chiang's there's this problem of of
know-how
and uh
the inability to capture this sort of
embedded knowledge in persons and it you
know it what what it what it sort of um
spoke to talk to what it said to me was
that like
yes like what we've clearly got here is
like a demonstration that there are
innate
knowledges experiences conventions that
are inarticulate in articular you know
you know
can't be said
in like can't be formalized in a you
know mathematical system let alone even
spoken in language right but this is
kind of like
the hayekian
jumping off point right and so
my question or my my thought is that
like this diagnosis doesn't necessarily
give us any political direction like we
can go in any direction from there like
we might say oh what we need now then is
like no prescriptive
rules we need like these really um
bottom-up
self-evolving spontaneous evolutionary
systems that are you know really mutable
and change all the time all we need like
uh to to to like have individuals like
reclaim their authority over
like particular outcome all we need is
organizational
like realignments to deal with the
problematic uh gap between an an
algorithm interpretation of reality and
what it actually is and so
i suppose the question is like how
well
you know
my question is like how do you take this
diagnosis and tune it towards a
particular political
way forward
i feel like i have a less sophisticated
version of jake's question so maybe i'll
just let them talk
synthesized
okay
well so i mean these are all great um my
question was for tom specifically
because one of the things that i found
really interesting about the
presentation was that the word politics
came up i think just like once in
reference to online radicalization which
i i don't mean in any way tom is a
critique of you
but of the paradigm that you are
imminently critiquing i think you
inhabited that world really successfully
and um yet as you show through your com
your concept of normative indeterminacy
ultimately the bedrock is some form of
politics or culture whatever you want to
call it which is to say irresolvable
disputes about values that come down to
like argumentation in a public sphere
and stuff like that you also pointed out
i think or speculated that in the future
these are going to have like radically
political importance in the way that
bernard was describing of like rules
that bind the lives of people and all
the rest of it through the way these
would become implemented in policy
um
so i guess the question i want to ask is
like
um
beyond the imminent critique how do you
make it clear to publics outside of this
community that this is a political
endeavor because i mean it falls in a
long line of using technocratic
management to substitute for politics by
other means but it is always political
right and so how do you how do you bring
that up to the surface and the public
debates that are going to happen around
these systems that that these
purportedly apolitical things are in
fact profoundly political
on these questions a little bit to come
as well and i think it's a similar
question when you take your two
examples the two examples that
i've heard you
mentioned before
um as if they're sort of representing
something similar that they feel to be
quite different
the the case of the
um
approach
that sort of gets into this weird cycle
it's being very literal literally
interpreting what it's supposed to do
versus
the case of the autonomous vehicle
systems
that are going to um
are going to
walk
watch
maybe the
unarticulated
conception of public roads
to kind of privatize those roads
these feel very very different like they
feel very different they they the wife
seems like a stupid mistake and the
other one you could say is like a self
but almost intended
consequence
of the two things and
i think um some of it
is due to some politics that isn't
expressed anyway
um
oh i i don't know if you have time for
one more question they will be time for
one more question but at the moment i'm
going to turn this because i'm also not
reading over the burden
of prayer
uh right so i guess a few of these were
directed to me um
[Music]
yeah i think it come it comes down to um
[Music]
for me a lot of these questions are are
practical about sort of like how i
how i also carry myself um
in in the ai research community um so
like i can talk analytically or
abstractly about my
like my theorization of this stuff but
yeah like what does the imminent
critique get up to well the answer is
i'm still figuring that out
uh there are a few things um one of it
is
um actively organizing um
the next generation of ai
theorists grad students what have you
to
basically like encourage them
i mean give them
try and instill in them a sense of
courage to think differently about these
questions
and so there's a lot of organizational
work that i do
uh as part of pearls
the political economy reinforcement
learning systems which is a
workshop that we held at nurip's last
year and we're hoping that will be a
biannual
event going forward which is really just
to sort of create
a kind um a ball work so to speak of um
heterodox thinking uh
within a tradition that otherwise is
just so secure in its assumptions that
it's never
there's there's just never a null
hypothesis that's even considered
there's nothing counterfactual going on
right
um that's one example another example is
i think um
somewhat more outward facing is new new
and i think more richer reflexive
approaches to ai documentation to show
the receipts so to speak of of how
systems actually work over time
and so my work on reward reports which
which helen is familiar with is
basically an attempt to document not
just the data
and not just the model but also like
what is the systems like optimizing for
like why is it doing what it's doing and
how does that like subvert
whatever the domain was before before
its operation and those are those are
distinct projects because really all my
talk was trying to show was like well
what what really are the decision points
in
throughout an ai pipeline the distinct
ones
um where politics is at stake where
politics happens where this
indeterminacy can get papered over um
and regarding helen's question as well
with like the boat example it's very
contrived it's very cartoonish
um but it's really not so different
actually than what xian was talking
about with like the
if if the optimal solution is to give a
single patient like three heart
transplants over like
six months
because of just the way they've
structured the data cluster or the way
the hospital understands it's like
budget or something like that
clearly that's not inhabiting this
notion of like end-of-life care
like palliative concerns like bedside
manner all these other fixtures of
what we would take good interventions to
be
but that have not yet been articulated
and so in answer to the question of like
to what extent
are our normative commitments
fundamentally inarticulable
that's actually a bit beyond my kin my
point was actually simpler which is
really just there's a bunch of norms
that matter to us
that we just haven't had to articulate
in law or some other system
and a lot of the politics just resides
in creating
the space
in which this articulation can happen
whether that's pearls whether that's
documentation whether that's
you know some other some other modality
and that's really pretty much all i do
is just try and create new spaces for
articulation
that's really inspiring i mean i would
totally agree with that i think the um
i mean just i've obviously referred to
two um theorists today both of them
can be reasonably sort of classed as
conservatives in their own way
um that's
that's a sort of lengthy debate in its
own right um the reason why i kind of
keep coming back to systems theory is
just i find it like a really compelling
way to generate questions for myself and
sort of put limits to what i would
otherwise assume
um
but i don't necessarily you know i'm not
that comfortable with the sort of
political implications of it but
generally i would say a couple of things
like one um
the political understanding of the world
is like there right we thought we've got
centuries of it and we have to hang on
to that and so you know i mean even
yesterday when helen was talking about
autonomy and um that kantian inheritance
i think that's super really important in
a way that's kind of the beginning of
intersubjectivity in in political
thinking you could say like this can't
so i think understanding those ideas and
doing the work of of theorizing them is
important but kind of more important is
exactly what thomas is saying like so
the way the way in which new
organizational structures to actually
reflect on what's going on and what
claims are being made and interrogating
them is like
that's that's that's the kind of systems
theory prediction anyway if there is one
it's like this will have this has to
happen and the danger of course and and
it's a very real danger politically is
that um
it's very possible to react to these
changes and more generally to the kind
of general crises of society
by
referring back to a kind of idea that we
do need to just reinstate a kind of
sovereign political decision maker and
um that currently takes the guys in
different discourses of ideas like the
common good or the nation state that's
all coming back
and i think it's it's been highly
critical and highly resistant to any
kind of moves to
try to differentiate or to take to
prevent these kinds of spaces and
discussions from emerging so
that's just my own orientation yeah
okay um i just a quick question i just
wonder if you guys can comment on how
much of this is
you know ml versus just digital
communications technologies in general
specifically the internet because it
feels like a lot of the problems and
issues that people are discussing aren't
you know specific to you know ml it's
more just
this is what happens when you put eight
billion people online and create
platforms that allow them to you know
communicate with each other thanks
what was the question uh that was beyond
um
the talk
and my talk at least um and the case
study i picked
um
focused on i think the most simplistic
form of ai or machine learning
um
in which
the
way the ai works in practice is not
fundam it's not categorically different
from other data
analytics you can see the whole like the
heart implant case study can be exactly
the same if it was an analytical system
with
i don't know just simple statistics
um
but there are i think machine learning
problems that are unique um and i
actually have written a paper called
whether y
whether when and why
human ai in action is particularly
difficult to design and just to
articulate that and i want to say
one challenge and
that ai brings is
these are living systems these systems
are
getting new data
every single time and every time it gets
new data it becomes a different system
arguably that the capability changes the
limitations change the way it fails
change
um that is why in the u.s currently in
healthcare so fda
federal
rugged administration
who approves these systems
um
requires
um each ai system to file for a new to
apply for a new license every time it
gets a new batch of training data and
that makes healthcare a particularly
good place to study because it's easier
because it's simpler it doesn't get new
data every it doesn't get trained on new
data well as ads systems recommendation
systems on
on search engines and and social media
platform or not they are constantly
changing and i think that the fact that
these systems are constantly evolving
and often co-evolving with people's
behaviors make ai a really difficult
thing to deal with
when considering harms when considering
politics and power balance among people
um
that's the answer
i just wanted you
to name this thought
your comments really kind of maybe
undermined the whole idea of this
this program
you're saying that you know there's no
essence of humanity so to the extent we
have some normative
goal that we're saying hey you know
guys
and we're going to hear a lot more from
the talks that are coming up
they're like critical
about the assumptions about humanity
that'll be as if there is a better way
of thinking or a different way
but what you've got us to
think is that there really is no essence
and uh humanity just is what the
zeitgeist
is and so should we just give it up
and let you manage to be whatever
so
i don't think yeah we should give up
like that's not
what i'm trying to say but i do think we
cannot talk about ai and humanity
without talking about which humans
i resist
calling all aiai just because you know
because a lot of the ai nowadays are
really just referring to simple
statistics
and humans
are so different
and let me use maybe just use the case
study as an example again
when these ai systems are not learning
from new data
the human the humanity in the system is
just what's already captured in the
electronic health record or whatever
other data that's there so there is a
finite set of
data that you can
that are representing humanity is
and then ai are just the ai is just
processing and like sort of getting new
insights or
ways of looking at that
representation
but whenever it's taking into new data
taking new data the nature of that
representation changes for example if we
actually bring
doctors discussion texts transcriptions
into the data then the ai represents the
doctor's discussion and the patient's
health record and whatnot so
it's such it becomes a changing
constantly changing
thing so so i
look at ai and humanity i think just
probably just one level more con more
like more nuanced or
lower level
um than than
some other discussions or at least like
the theoretical discussions i think sort
of requires us by nature we look at this
at one level higher but it's just
looking at a different level i think
[Music]
i mean i guess i'm glad that that
provocation came across um
yeah and it's funny that you said that
because
one of them said this little clips was
like you know when when he's asked about
what what does man do what does a human
do he says which one you know so
um so that that's exactly the response
that you gave which is which is funny
but i think there's a couple of points
one is um that uh
i think
you know
it's not you know you not not to get too
romantic about it but this idea that um
the society is a sort of fragile
achievement i think matters a lot and i
think that the the that there are
ways of expressing love that there are
ways of
um
making art you know that there are um
ways of being different in the world and
constantly becoming different in the
world
um
we can you know in a very sort of
post-modern way just various theories
about this but we know that can be
something that in itself is like
meta-normative to use that kind of
loaded term um so that's that's one
response and then of course the flip
side is just to draw attention to the
danger that um
an assertion of a strong human essence
usually brings with it which i think is
usually a threat to other ways of
existing other modalities of being
and it's just but just to reiterate that
we we do we do have the critical
resources already in society and the ai
is it ai is it the internet
yeah it's maybe not that important you
know because
it is about society's responses to these
things and and but it's just always i
think the point i wanted to deliver is
just to say
this problem of contingency will always
recur and yeah that's where it stops
thank you very much